madame danielle tremblay bonjour alors
c'est moi j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à
vous lire je suis de ceux qui adorent
faire la lecture de ce que vous avez
couché sur le papier lorsque vous faites
vos voyages vous le fait pratiquement
tous les soirs à la fin de la journée ou
sinon lendemain matin et je pense
souvent à vous en termes de jane bang de
celles qui veulent entrer plus jamais
dit mais je vous le dis vous allez dans
des situations particulières vous en
ressortez complètement indemne mais
finalement vous prenez de sérieux
risques lorsque vous êtes allés au
honduras est ce que vous vous attendiez
un monde tellement différent des autres
dire que vous êtes dans un pays où faut
faire attention à soi
non je savais qu'il y avait de la
criminalité en amérique latine ya là un
peu partout mais je ne savais pas que
c'était à ce point locke c'était le pays
les plus criminalisés de toute
l'amérique centrale souffre est clair et
donc il faut effectivement fabien
natation au premier abord ça semble pas
comme ça mais c'est en étant aux côtés
de ma clientèle yeux j'ai cru comprendre
les dajic pouvait subvenir
or il n'est pas question de marcher le
soir n'est pas question de mettre des
affiches de commerce sur la devanture
d'une maison par exemple
ayez toujours la conduite automobile à
ma moi je suis dit pour conclure avec
des herbes des femmes prennent pour
ayrton senna à certain moment donné
parce que il faut pas arrêter au foot
sorte il est surtout pas fort simple
comme ça aussi au brésil ailleurs mais
dans un petit pays comme cela se passe
pour qu'elle soit aussi grave il faut
faire attention il faut être très très
vigilant il faut être très prudent et
les gens qui ont de l'argent ben eux
vivent dans des espaces de tout revoir
complètement isolé complètement fermé
des 28 alliés de l'amérique latine mais
là ça m'a vraiment peut-être saute au
visage davantage parce que c'est c'est
la classe de jacques et je fréquentais
quand j'étais là et donc ça chatouille à
un canadien un peu plus et là vous
le soir faire attention mais des
cuisines où la scène mettez nous dans le
taux je ne sais pas où par dider tonnes
sénat à vos côtés en pleine journée en
plein jour
vous circulez à tombeau ouvert
vous avez peur pour votre vie vous vous
rendez où vous venez d'où qu'est ce que
vous faites des zianides ma cliente nous
invite pour le lunch les habitats la
montagne c'est des gens qui ont beaucoup
d'argent et bondois sarralbe un moment
donné lauaki a puisqu'il n'y a pas de
revanche
non mais on peut pas on peut pas il faut
rouler et c'est ici parce que c'est une
zone qui est un peu dangereuse parce
qu'être comme effectivement plus loin
c'est des gens qui sont impuissants
cossu qui a peut-être là bas mais ils
sont un peu tête arnaquer alors si tel
malade à ralentir un peu
on a sept à voiture alors je vous dis
pas que dans les montagnes avec les
courbes sinueuses et tout et tout il
faut bien se tenir et elle avait un
espèce de cap pas cap avec la poignée
comme ça sur la côte est de la boucle
mais ce n'est pas ça m'a lâché ma
poignée
c'est mieux mais avec la sec avec la
broche sa voie de recours prévues mais
vraiment et son profil sur
l'accélérateur
on peut lire c'est tellement vous êtes
arrivé à destination et le viennent
c'est quand même une autre scène de jean
bonne vous vous arrivez dans un endroit
où c'est comme un bunker
il ya des gens qui habitent dans un
autre monde qui sont sur une autre
planète des gens extrêmement riche vous
rencontrez je pense le président de la
peau de la banque mondiale est ce que
j'exagère ou quoi et en mai et s'en est
allé plus tôt et puis lui aussi il est
protégé par des gardes du corps vous
sentez prêt de nervosité toujours dans
cet environnement en boîte et il ya un
aspect où effectivement il ya de la
sécurité ya des ces clôtures et ses
barbelés il ya des gardes à l'entrée et
latin édifice branlant 15 étages et où
l'autre le fond
on est peut-être la barre mondial tous
les gens qui travaillent pour des ong à
des postes de haute direction sans
presque tout de même building finalement
parce que ses seuls endroits au brésil
où elle est habitée et devant les
prisons hors norme et c'est une façon de
visiter cet amas de palier à lens c'est
pratiquement il était évident il ces
gens là ils vous ils ont des
conversations tout à fait normal avec
vous ils vous traite pas un subalterne
vous êtes copain-copain assuma pas le
suit pour aider à développer certains
clients et damart bon il ferait avec des
conseillers volontaires ces gens là pas
mal plus tard alors non sont habitués
aux établissements je n'ai pas la
garde-robe pour l'occasion mais le
ménage sur l'amérique latine dans votre
petite valise de jean bonne foi au moins
vingt trois a baissé sur bonaventure
finalement et qu'est-ce que vous alliez
faire quand vous dites je viens venez en
aide à quelqu'un c'est quelqu'un qui
avait véritablement besoin de l'aide du
canada
c'est une dame qui est sociologue qui
avait un mari ingénieur quand même qui
vivait très bien qu'ils vivent toujours
très bien mais le mari est décédé et
donc la dame qui a des habits qui était
d'aider des gens un peu moins fortunés
qui travaillait la poterie la céramique
linta de type links à qui est typique de
la région
bella est obligée de comment vous à
continuer de mettre le pied sur
l'accélérateur dans ce que l'on doit
subvenir à ses propres besoins et à son
groupe de femmes mais on a presque 250
et évidemment les quatre enfants qui
sont aux études en europe alors il faut
il faut vendre
alors monsieur allait lui donner un coup
de main au niveau de son plan marketing
pour l'orienter davantage parce que bon
côté sociologue pas nécessairement les
outils ou peut-être que tu les hommes et
sont peut-être pas aussi raffinée alors
moi je suis là pour vraiment appuyer ces
cas-là phare sur le plan marketing
est ce que c'est quand même 250 emplois
de sam un peu moins nantis qui en
dépendent aussi alors elle réussit à
faire dit ces gens là et il faut quand
même que vous jouez y ait du coude
lorsque vous étiez sur place vous avez
noté que ont volé les idées de cette
dame là au niveau de l'artisanat des
petits commerçants qui faisait ça oui la
copie évidemment j'ai copié industriels
plus haut niveau mais ce à tous les
niveaux 1 et effectivement il a fallu
qu'on joue un peu au james bond pourra
prendre à terme à james bond et d'aller
voir ce que ses concurrents alors bon
c'était quoi exactement qui copiait les
prix et tout pour la bonne stratégie
pour contrer ces gens là et vous
déguiser votre identité la personne ne
suis absolument pas se fait passer pour
une femme dont le mari travaille et si
j'avais des achats de dernière minute
alors on s'est créé un petit budget puis
on était capable de sortir les prix
comme ça vous êtes une femme riche mais
on prépare en bon a coûté finalement
l'histoire se termine bien vous avez
réussi à aider cette dame en difficulté
avec tous ces soucis toutes ces
personnes qui dépendent elles de dell
est déjà fin se porte au mieux les
attaques entraînent alors vous la voir
régulièrement faire des salons pendant
que les talents de sam a préparé un
salon pour la ford 2001 et continue
aujourd'hui à alors non ça va chaque
année sa nouvelle collection évidemment
et comme et le lait puis établi il ya
des conseillers volonté y arriverons à
sa boutique alors on a vraiment appuyé
par ses bons à payer ce genre d'après
nos diverses tout le monde veut savoir
quel sera notre prochain dessine
si y en a des tonnes avec vous et cela
m'avait thème est ce qu'on n'est pas
déjà allé en bolivie on est déjà en
bolivie nationale on est déjà lancée dès
aux philippines
oui on retourne au burkina bon d'accord
commandeur qui n'a plus là on pourra
parler de beurre de karité on pourra
parler des artisans on pourra parler des
gens qui ont des associations
d'handicapés sont aussi artisans safran
vos choix
bon jeu pensez vous qu'il y avait pas
mal décidé de la faire merci beaucoup
madame tremblay a fait très plaisir
bonne semaine